now to washington president biden says
he will work like hell direct quote to
bring democratic lawmakers together
overcoming disagreement about his
ambitious agenda party leaders insist
they just need a little more time all
right o'keefe is at the white house
monitoring all this for us ed good
morning to you good morning tony you
know normally here in washington work
has slowed down because of fights
between democrats and republicans over
big legislation well right now it's
because of fighting amongst democrats
liberals and moderates can't agree
exactly on how to proceed and now some
activists are confronting two of the
senators at the middle of the fight
[Music]
on sunday in arizona activists followed
senator kirsten cinema into a ladies
room angered by her opposition to a 3.5
trillion dollar social policy bill
in washington other activists have even
circled the houseboat of west virginia
senator joe manchin who tried addressing
their concerns and i know it won't be
enough for some it'll be too much for
others the anger comes as democrats blew
through their own deadlines failing last
week to pass a bipartisan infrastructure
bill and failing to cut a deal amongst
themselves over president biden's
buildback better plan the president
spent the weekend mostly out of public
view seven hundred thousand covades can
we get your reaction sir as other top
democrats say they'll keep at it our
goal is to get it done in the next month
both bills and get them passed the
bipartisan infrastructure bill is
expected to eventually pass in the house
but only if a deal is reached on the
size and scope of the much larger second
bill packed with changes in health care
education housing and climate change
policy
moderates like manchin say they won't
support spending more than 1.5 trillion
dollars on the plan
progressives disagree it's going to be
somewhere you know between 1.5 and 3.5
new york congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez explained how progressives
might find a way to bring down the price
i think that one of the ideas that's out
there is fully fund
what we can fully fund but maybe instead
of doing it for 10 years you fully fund
it for five years
as the talks continue the president's
planning to hit the road to sell the
plan even though we don't entirely know
yet what's actually in it he plans to
visit michigan tomorrow with possible
stops later in the week gail
all right he said he was going to work
like hell seems like he needs to do that
thank you very much